[Music]
Risa's with us in New Jersey
hey Reese how are you mr. Ramsey I just
have a quick question for you
I've been juggling the idea back and
forth of my head of getting rid of my
current vehicle and downgrading to a
cheaper one in hopes of expediting my
baby step two I just kind of wanted your
thoughts what do y'all want it I owe
14,500 what's your income forty nine
thousand dollars and my first my main
job and then five thousand and a side
job good for you how old are you 26 good
and how much other debt other than the
car this is where it gets kind of sticky
the majority of my debt is a student
debt just shy of $47,000 hmm okay that's
it you do you owe on the car fourteen
thousand fourteen what's it worth it's
worth Kelley Blue Book I just checked
13,000 so I'm upside down 1500 mmm-hmm
okay all right so if I just do I do big
number math is the way I do this here's
how it works okay so I got 14 and 40 is
54 in debt right yeah 45 for the student
loans okay so 59 59 60 in debt okay and
you and you're making you said 40 plus
the part-time job right yeah 49 plus 5
for a total of 54 okay so if we pay off
$30,000 a year for two years you're
debt-free out of 54 you're 26 and single
that's beans and rice you can do that
yes sir or instead of paying off 30 in
two years you could pay off what would
it be if we took that 14 off right
that'd be seven less a year and so
instead of 30 a year it'd be 23 a year
so to that it's $2,000 a month if you
don't keep the car it's $2,500 a month
if you do keep the car
if you're unwilling to cut your budget
that deep you should sell the car okay
because I would want you to be debt-free
in two years so I'm doing some very
simple math there are you following me I
mean it's nothing not no rocket science
involved here it's just now I'm taking
your $54,000 income and putting you on
no life budget either way really and so
the only question is are you going to be
out of debt in 18 months or in two years
do you like the car a lot yeah I really
do like it a lot
cool what kind of car is it Toyota
Corolla that's gonna come 2014 yeah it's
not bad
good cars these that's kind of my I'm
sorry good no it's okay it's just if I'm
in your shoes and that's the way I
answer questions here I would be willing
to cut my lifestyle in order to keep my
car
okay that's kind of my thought process
because it's like I can you know sell it
downgrade it gets me out of debt you
know maybe six to eight months faster
but exactly I'm but I'm out of debt and
with you know with a hoody as opposed to
you know eight extra months and I have a
car that should in theory last another
twenty years I don't feel that far but
it'll last a lot longer than I hoped II
and you won't turn around move up in car
as soon as you finish that snowball so
your Theory's right except for that last
a little bit but the yeah and here's the
thing you just got to commit to a twenty
five hundred bucks a month
okay that's thirty thousand a year
that's sixty thousand and two and so and
until I get to that we don't eat out
unless you're working in a restaurant
you know and we're not going the movie
unless you're working that and you're
not gonna spend any money you don't have
any money you're getting out of debt so
you're gonna sacrifice social life party
time whatever it is you do with money
that you used to do with money and
you're gonna put all your freaking money
on this and you're gonna be done by the
time you're twenty eight can you imagine
what it would be like to have no
payments in the world literally can't
imagine you're on your way brother
you're gonna do it
and I'm gonna get to talk to you you're
gonna call me back into your debt free
scream right here I can tell I'm coming
down to Nashville for that I love it man
I'll give you a personal high-five love
it
get after it brother you got this